humans are proud of a lot of things from
particle accelerators to poetry to
pokemon
all of them made possible because of
something humans value extremely highly
intelligence
we think of intelligence as a trait like
height or strength but when we try to
define it things get fuzzy in a nutshell
intelligence is a mechanism to solve
problems especially the problem of
staying alive which involves finding
food and shelter fighting sexual
competitors or fleeing from predators
intelligence is not a single thing it
includes the ability to gather knowledge
to learn be creative form strategies or
engage in critical thinking
it manifests itself in a huge variety of
behaviors
from hardwired or instinct-like
reactions to different degrees of
learning to some sort of awareness
but not all scientists agree where it
begins or what even should count as
intelligence to make this even more
complicated intelligence is also
connected to consciousness since
awareness is helpful for problem solving
but we're exploring consciousness in
other videos so today we'll leave it
aside
okay intelligence isn't exactly
clear-cut so maybe we can think of it as
more like a flexible set of skills a
toolbox
basic tools
the most basic tools in the intelligence
toolbox are the ability to gather
information to save it and to use it to
learn
information about the world is gathered
through senses such as vision sound
smell touch or taste
and helps us navigate and react to the
external world appropriately
but living things also need to keep
track of the state of their own bodies
monitoring things like hunger and
fatigue
information is the basis of action for
all living things and without it you're
at the mercy of your surroundings unable
to react appropriately or flexibly
information is much more powerful if we
can keep and save it so the second tool
is memory
memory is the ability to save and recall
information so a living being doesn't
have to start from scratch every time it
perceives something relevant
memories can be about events places and
associations but also behaviors like
hunting or foraging methods
some of these like flying have to be
repeated over and over until they're
mastered this is what we call learning
the process of putting together a
sequence of thoughts or actions
basically a string of repeatable
behaviors that can be varied and adapted
these three tools enable seemingly
stupid creatures to act in surprisingly
intelligent ways
the acellular slime mold which is
basically just a single huge slimy cell
shows behavior similar to an animal with
a simple brain
when put in a maze with food at one end
the slime mold explores its surroundings
and marks its path with slime trails
sort of smearing memories on the ground
as it continues exploring it avoids the
marked pathways and finds its way to the
food
instead of blindly getting stuck in dead
ends the slime mold adapts its behavior
to save time and effort this behavior is
hardwired and scientists can't agree if
that's intelligent although it does give
the slime mold a certain advantage
these are an example of more adaptive
smart behavior
scientists trained bumblebees to move a
coloured ball into a goal post for a
sugar reward not only were the bees very
skillful at this behavior which isn't
natural to them they got more efficient
over time
when several balls were available bees
chose the ball that lay closest to the
goal even if it was a different color
than the ball they were trained with
[Music]
for more challenging problems we need
even more flexibility
fancier tools
building on the basic tools more complex
animals have a wider range of problems
they can solve
they can memorize all kinds of
associations connections and mechanical
tricks we'll call this tool the library
of knowledge
take raccoons their favorite kind of
food is human food
their approach to getting hold of such
treats depends upon an assortment of
theoretical and practical skills that
makes them master burglars able to open
windows or pick locks
in a study raccoons were given boxes
secured with different kinds of locks
like latches bolts plugs or push bars
they needed less than 10 attempts to
figure out how to open each box
even when different locks were put
together into increasingly difficult
combinations that had to be solved in
the right order and with different
amounts of strength
a year later the raccoons still
remembered how to open the boxes and
were as fast as when they had first
solved the puzzle
[Music]
our library of associations and skills
the most impressive tool in our box is
creativity a sort of mental dux tape
being creative means producing something
new and valuable from apparently
unrelated things
in the context of intelligence this
means making new and unusual connections
pairing input with memories and skills
to come up with a unique solution to a
problem
in another raccoon study researchers
showed the animals that by dropping
pebbles into a water tank they could
raise the water level enough to reach a
marshmallow floating at the top
one raccoon came up with a much better
solution it tipped the tub over
another facet of creativity is applying
a new resource to a task physical tools
like primates that use sticks to fish
for termites in trees or some octopuses
which assemble collected coconut shells
around themselves as a sort of portable
armor to hide from enemies
collecting materials for later use is
connected to an even more advanced
dimension of problem solving planning
planning means considering the
activities required for a desired goal
and putting them together in a plan
when unforeseen circumstances and new
possibilities present themselves they
need to be assessed according to whether
they match the plan or not
an example of this intelligent behavior
is hoarding food to eat it later
this is an instinctive behavior in
squirrels but even though hiding food
comes instinctively to them they still
need to use advanced thinking skills to
make the best decisions
squirrels examine every nut and weigh
the time and effort it would take to
hide it against the benefits they would
get from each one
damage to all low fat nuts are eaten
right away while nuts that still need to
ripen go on the stockpile
squirrels also pretend to bury nuts when
they feel watched
these empty caches distract rivals from
their real treasure
this is pretty advanced strategizing
because to make a plan to distract
someone else you first have to be aware
that there are others like you that want
the same things
the more complex the problem the more
tools are needed in combination to solve
it so the more tools there are the more
flexibility a being has to solve the
challenges life throws at them
but even for complex problems each
animal's individual situation is what
counts
squirrels are omnivores that defend
their territories fiercely
for them it makes sense to remember
where there's food in different
locations and trick their enemies to
improve their chances of survival
sheep don't have any such refined tricks
up their sleeve but they don't need to
they are grazers and live in flogs the
skills relevant to them are social they
recognize and remember many different
sheep and even humans for years a
completely different skill
evolving and retaining a complex set of
mental abilities they might never use
would be a waste of resources for them
humans went the opposite way and
invested in an unusually diverse
intelligence toolkit
while this was helpful by accident we
added another set of tools on top
culture
no single person could ever build a
space rocket or particle accelerator
but thanks to our ability to work
together and to share knowledge across
generations we can overcome challenges
beyond any single individual's ability
this allowed us to shape the planet to
our liking we also created new problems
in the process sudoku tax forms string
theory
but also rapid climate change and
antibiotic resistance
to solve these we'll need to look past
short-term survival and think about the
distant future
we have the toolbox we just need to use
it
speaking of tools for learning we've
heard from many teachers that are using
our infographic posters in class
so we asked what would help them the
most and made an education edition for
teachers students and everyone else
their slightly larger post is about
various things that will expand over
time from a periodic table to a world
map or the human body
you can get them in our shop and support
us if you want and let us know which
post topics you want for your room or
classroom
this video was part two of a three-part
video series relating to big questions
of life and the universe made possible
thanks to a grant from the templeton
world charity foundation you'll find our
sources and further reading in the video
description
[Music]
you